elle m'a dit vous savez madame Mousset
moi quand j'ai vu l'état de vos valves
je savais que vous étiez une patiente
qui avait pris du médiateur
nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20h ce soir Muriel Rousset
[Applaudissements]
alors Muriel vous avez pris du Médiator
ce médicament des laboratoires Servier
prescrit au départ au diabétique en
surcharge pondérale mais pris par la
suite par beaucoup de gens qui
désiraient perdre du poids résultat
d'après vous ceci a été la cause de
votre opération du cœur en 2007 à l'âge
de 39 ans et vous dites que votre vie
est désormais celle d'une petite vieille
tout à fait
médiator black odeur du scandale 2010 on
en reparle à 20h
[Musique]
Muriel robonçoire vous êtes né le 11 mai
1966 à Lyon part en fonctionnaire
employé de mairie vous êtes l'aîné d'une
famille de trois enfants et vous vous
occupez des deux petits comme une
deuxième maman vous êtes donc très
bienveillante dynamique rieuse
après le collège vous voulez rentrer
rapidement dans la vie active vous
faites un BEP de secrétariat
administratif faut dire que dès l'âge de
15 ans vous aviez rencontré votre amour
à 18 ans vos mariés
et à 19 ans vous êtes déjà maman
d'un petit Michael voilà votre vie
professionnelle se passe également très
bien à 20 ans vous êtes attachés de
direction dans une entreprise
d'informatique à 24 ans vous entrez à la
mairie de Lyon et à l'âge où la plupart
des femmes cherchent l'âme sœur vous
vous divorcez déjà alors là vous en avez
marre de passer vos journées devant un
ordinateur dans un bureau vous vous
mettez à bosser dans des bars et des
restaurants et c'est à cette époque que
vous rencontrez le père de votre
deuxième enfant à l'époque où vous êtes
serveuse dans une discothèque de la
banlieue lyonnaise qui s'appelle
l'arc-en-ciel en 1998 le deuxième enfant
Calvin né vous êtes heureuse très
heureuse mais la grossesse vous a laissé
quelques kilos en trop je n'arrivais
plus à éliminer donc
j'ai entendu parler de médiateurs car
c'était vraiment le médicament qui était
à la mode tout le monde en parlait je me
suis fait aider oui avec ce médicament
qui était un coupe-faim et je ne savais
pas du tout à l'époque qu'il était donné
pour les diabétiques c'était l'Allier de
la minceur de la forme pour rester belle
pour rester dans le coup six mois après
donc les résultats sont satisfaisants
grâce aux médiator plus le régime vous
avez perdu 8 kg 10
pas mal mais en 2003 vous généralement
si dynamique si pétillante vous sentez
une immense fatigue s'abattre sur vous à
l'époque vous gériez quand même 70
couverts d'un seul coup vous n'arrivez
plus à faire votre travail vous n'avez
jamais été malade auparavant
donc vous vous dites c'est l'âge moi je
voyais la chose comme ça parce que
j'avais jamais été malade et je me suis
dit bon ben il est peut-être temps que
que j'arrête ce travail et que je
retourne travailler dans les bureaux
vous inscrivez à l'ANPE malheureusement
il vous sera très difficile de retrouver
du boulot Muriel en même temps j'étais
de plus en plus fatiguée donc oui je
recherche un emploi mais c'était
difficile vous êtes au chômage depuis un
an quand les kilos reviennent et là
médiator en plus c'est remboursé par la
sécu donc c'est pas cher et vous y allez
vous recommencez aux médiateur le
médecin vous prescrit une cure de six
mois
en 2005 vous êtes toujours au chômage
mais en fin de droit cette fois vous
avez deux enfants à charge vous
retrouvez au RMI et là évidemment bon
l'inaction le stress la déprime les
kilos reviennent
troisième cure de médiateur cette fois
six mois
en décembre 2005 vous êtes hospitalisé
deux semaines pour une pneumonie qui est
assez facilement guéri il faut le dire
d'hospitalisation et puis et puis sortie
d'hôpital c'est début décembre mais
avant votre départ de l'hôpital le
médecin chef vous propose une
échographie du coeur une fois rentré
chez vous vous dites finalement ma
pneumonie est guérie qu'est-ce que je
vais aller m'embêter à faire cette
échographie du coeur mais votre fils
vous pousse quand je suis rentrée à midi
et j'avais rendez-vous à 14h je me suis
dit non j'ai pas envie j'étais fatiguée
je n'avais pas envie de retourner et là
mon fils qui à l'époque avait 19 ans m'a
dit non maman faut y aller tu l'as
jamais fait c'est l'occasion alors quand
vous êtes allongé sur la table vous
remarquez que les internes sont très
inquiets en vous regardant
l'une dit qu'elle va chercher un
cardiologue
et elle vous dit si vous étiez ma sœur
je ne laisseraient pas dans cet état
tout à fait quand le cardiologue arrive
il y a un malaise
d'abord il y a le silence total
et puis m'annonce que j'ai une valve qui
fonctionne très difficilement et qui est
complètement califié donc là j'ai pas
compris ce qui m'arrivait du tout il
vous annonce que l'une de vos valves
cardiaques est en très mauvais état et
qu'une opération à cœur ouvert est
absolument nécessaire je me suis dit
c'est pas possible j'avais l'impression
de vivre un cauchemar je suis quand même
allée voir un autre cardiologue en
espérant qu'il me disent ils se sont
trompés mais non le diagnostic est
elle-même et
en fait vous n'aviez pas une valve
cardiaque endommagée mais deux et
gravement elle a ça devenait très urgent
alors avant l'opération vous êtes
prévenu vous ne pourrez plus avoir
d'enfant et vous serez obligé de prendre
des anticoagulants jusqu'à la fin de vos
jours tous les jours
sinon risque d'AVC cardiaque la veille
de l'opération vous dites docteur si je
fais pas l'opération il me reste combien
de temps à vivre et il vous dites deux
trois mois tout au plus j'avais envie de
reculer un petit peu cette opération
j'avais très peur et quand il m'a
annoncé deux mois trois mois et avec
plein d'interrogations je me suis assise
sur Lire résigner en fait j'avais plus
de choix alors là vous embrassez vos
enfants un peu comme si vous ne deviez
plus jamais les voir ça a été très dur
de pas leur faire ne pas leur
transmettre ma peur et et j'avais
d'ailleurs décidé de ne pas en parler à
ma mère parce qu'elle est très émotive
et en réfléchissant je me suis dit non
je n'ai pas le droit de faire ça si
toutefois je me réveille pas elle m'en
aurait voulu alors suite à cette
opération à cœur ouvert vous avez des
douleurs absolument intenables dans la
cage thoracique
et le médecin vous dit parce que lui il
avait vu évidemment l'état des valves
cardiaques il vous dit madame vous étiez
à trois semaines d'un arrêt cardiaque
massif
j'aurais pas pu fêter mes 40 ans en fait
je serai pas arrivé à mes 40 ans
alors là vous découvrez la peur de
mourir évidemment la terreur parce que
les médecins finalement ils ont recul de
de 20 ans alors je comptais 45 ans et
après il se passe quoi et vous savez
j'ai eu très très peur de mourir j'étais
terrorisée même après l'opération
j'ai pleuré des sodas je téléphonais à
mes parents à mes sœurs en mon seul
souci était mes enfants promettez-moi
que vous les laisserai pas promettez-moi
que que vous serez là pour eux parce que
on n'a pas peur pour nous dans ces cas
là on pense aux gens qu'on aime surtout
évidemment cette opération vous condamne
à l'inaction ce qui fait que vos kilos
reviennent et là quatrième cure de
médiator et oui parce que loin de penser
que c'était ce médicament qui faisait
ces choses là
et finalement c'est en 2009 que vous
découvrez le livre de Irène Frachon
elle était au CHU de Brest c'est une
dame formidable que j'ai eu au téléphone
qui m'a beaucoup réconforté qui m'a dit
qu'ils connaissait mes valves du fait
que le chirurgien qui m'avait opéré avec
6 autres personnes avaient fait une
publication médicale tellement mon cœur
était une énigme l'état de mes valves
était une énigme et quand j'ai eu au
téléphone elle m'a dit vous savez madame
Rousset moi quand j'ai vu l'état de vos
valves je savais que vous étiez une
patiente qui avait pris du Médiator à la
lecture du livre vous êtes plus de
panique là vous allez sur Internet et
vous découvrez que vous n'êtes pas tout
seul dans ce cas là c'est là que vous
prenez conscience en fait de l'influence
du Médiator sur l'état de vos valves
cardiaques et vous décidez de porter
plainte
alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'entre
1976 et 2009 plus de 500 personnes
seraient mortes en France à cause du
Médiator pourtant un autre médicament
chimiquement proche et du même
laboratoire l'isomérie avait été retirée
du marché en 1997
alors les effets néfastes du principe
actif du Médiator sur les vaves
cardiaques ont été démontrés aux USA en
2000 en 1898 il avait été déclaré
hautement toxique en espagnol en 2003
donc est-ce que la vie d'un Suisse ou
d'un Espagnol est plus précieux que la
vie d'un Français je ne pense pas
si ce produit avait été retiré en temps
voulu quand IRM Frachon attiré la
sonnette d'alarme aujourd'hui je serai
pas là je serai pas malade je serai
quelqu'un de libre de une maman normale
alors aujourd'hui les autorités
sanitaires demandent à tous ceux qui ont
pris du médiateur de consulter un
médecin
mais ça fait quand même 5 millions de
patients
alors Servier c'est un laboratoire
extrêmement important c'est le deuxième
laboratoire français derrière Sanofi
Aventis et le propriétaire Monsieur
Servier a déclaré en parlant de ce
scandale c'est un bruit médiatique
disproportionné
quand vous entendez ça vous réagissez
comment je deviens folle parce que tout
le monde tout le monde parle de tout le
monde en parle tout le monde s'en mêle
et eux c'est le silence radio donc moi
au jour d'aujourd'hui si je suis là
c'est si vous pouvez me regarder je leur
poserai une question je leur demanderai
si ça avait été leur femme leur fille un
membre de la famille ou ne serait-ce
qu'un ami est-ce qu'ils auraient accepté
de leur donner ce produit non non et
tout ça a été fait pour des raisons
économiques et on peut pas accepter ça
de la bousillé notre vie je ne suis plus
libre
Monsieur Mélenchon
mettre un petit bémol sur au moins une
chose tous les médecins n'ont pas
prescrit
médiateur bon il s'agit d'abord
maintenant de prendre des mesures pour
que ceux qui sont malades sans le savoir
puissent aller se faire soigner dans
dans de bonnes conditions quel que soit
leur fortune ou leur pas de fortune ça
c'est la première fois après il faut
quand même un peu réfléchir pas comme
une chose pareille est possible les
dirigeants des firmes pharmaceutiques
tout le système qui est en place qui
préfère prendre des risques que de
perdre de l'argent et qui pousse à la
consommation d'un produit qui est de
notoriété publique et dangereuse c'est
interdit ailleurs est-ce que vous pensez
que Servier devrait être entendu par les
autorités quand même il faut bien quand
même qu'il assume sa responsabilité cet
homme pour le moment lui il parle à
personne non mais j'espère au moins
qu'il ressent une responsabilité humaine
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est quand
même une des accumulations de profit les
plus fabuleuses du pays l'autre là-bas
il a encore sa belle vie devant lui les
gens qui ont été pris dans cette
histoire c'est terminé il faut les
toucher là où ça leur fait mal à eux
alors je vais faire mon échelle quand
vous achetez des médicaments si vous
voyez serviés à médicaments égal acheter
l'autre non mais il faut déjà les mettre
à l'attaque il faut que ils assument
financièrement leur responsabilité à
l'égard des personnes qu'ils ont rendu
malade
il faut vraiment il faut les résultats
de l'enquête surtout ces sujets merci de
votre témoignage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu